schweden ist vorreiter beim erreichen
der klimaziele ein land dass eines
seiner für 2030 gesteckten klimaziele
höchstwahrscheinlich schon im kommenden
jahr schaffen wird wow wie dieser erfolg
zu erklären ist was sich andere länder
von schweden abgucken können und wie
deutschland im ranking abschneidet das
alles und noch viel mehr erfahren sie
jetzt bei klicks und seinen wünschen bei
uns gibt's täglich science videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts herzlich willkommen der
meeresspiegel steigt an die antarktis
schmilzt es gibt immer mehr dürren und
auch hier bei uns werden die
wetterphänomene immer extremer wenn wir
nichts ändern wird die temperatur in der
antarktis bis im jahr 2070 um krasse
drei grad ansteigen und das hätte
katastrophale folgen für uns alle doch
wir haben es in der hand wenn wir uns
nämlich mal zusammenreißen würden und
uns an klima und umweltschutz regeln
halten würden sie das szenario für die
zukunft schon viel rosiger aus dann
nämlich würde die temperatur deutlich
geringer ansteigen
um genau das zu erreichen haben viele
länder klimaschutzziele vereinbart die
eu beispielsweise hat sich bis zum jahr
2030 drei hauptziele auf die fahne
geschrieben
demnach sollen im vergleich zum jahr
1990 die treibhausgasemissionen um
mindestens 40 prozent reduziert werden
dagegen sollen der anteil der
erneuerbaren energiequellen und auch die
energieeffizienz jeweils um 27 prozent
erhöht werden
das hatten die eu-regierungschefs im
oktober 2014 vereinbart in diesem
zusammenhang hat schweden jetzt eine
sehr erfreuliche nachricht verkündet das
energieministerium will schon bis zum
jahresende rund 28 terawattstunden an
erneuerbaren energien produzieren diese
masse bei ursprünglich mal als ein ziel
für das jahr 2030 vorgesehen die soll
mit knapp 3700 neuen windturbinen
passieren die jährlich knapp 20
terawattstunden energie produzieren
könnten
bis 2040 dann will das skandinavische
land es schaffen seinen kompletten strom
aus erneuerbaren energien zu erzeugen
dazu die schwedische klima ministerin
isabella levin in einem interview wenn
man sich einmal einen ruck gibt und
einfach loslegt geht alles ganz schnell
dazu muss man sagen dass es für schweden
aufgrund seiner geografie relativ 1
ach ist energie aus wind und wasserkraft
zu erzeugen dennoch ein super erfolg der
echt zu würdigen ist dazu kommt dass die
schweden innerhalb der eu für
ehrgeizigere klimaschutzziele einsetzt
und so liegt das skandinavische land in
dem ranking der europäischen
nichtregierungsorganisationen kein auf
platz eins und zwar mit 77 prozent der
von canon geforderten maßnahmen bei der
can bewertung ging es darum inwieweit
die länder bezüglich des ausbaus der
erneuerbaren energien sind und wie sich
die pro-kopf-emissionen entwickelt haben
in das ranking floss auch mit ein wie
sich die länder auf eu ebene für
strengere klimaziele einsetzen
ja und auf der rangliste hinter schweden
folgen portugal frankreich die
niederlande und luxemburg erst auf platz
sieben kommt dann deutschland kurz vor
litauen und kroatien beispielsweise weit
abgehängt also und tatsächlich schon im
klimaschutzbericht von 2017 hatte das
umweltministerium zugegeben seine ziele
für 2020 nicht zu erreichen bis dahin
werde man beispielsweise den ausstoß von
treibhausgasen nur um rund 30 prozent
reduzieren können
eigentlich bei einer reduktion um 40
prozent angepeilt das ist nicht einmal
35 prozent werden war eine riesige
enttäuschung doch der bericht liefert
auch die gründe dafür oder sommer lieber
ausreden sagen zum einen habe das
bevölkerungswachstum unerwartet deutlich
zugenommen das liege an den vielen
schutzsuchenden die aus anderen ländern
geflohen sind und seit 2015 in
deutschland leben und so auch mehr
energie verbraucht wird zum anderen habe
es eine unerwartete dynamische korrektur
entwicklung gegeben einen
wirtschaftsboom also unter anderem liege
das wiederum an niedrigen preisen für
gas kohle und öl und das bedeutet dann
eben auch mehr produktion verkehr und am
langen ende auch mehr schadstoffe laut
der organisation für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und entwicklung oecd sei
es gerade in der aktuellen situation
eine umso dringender aufgabe der
deutschen politik intensiv und hart
gegen die schlechte klimabilanz des
landes vorzugehen
die oecd bezieht sich dabei
beispielsweise auf den kohle-ausstieg
hier ist deutschland in der rolle des
größten braunkohle förderers weltweit
ein möglicher lösungsansatz wäre ein co2
dieses preis umweltschützer fordern
fordern diesen schon seit längerer zeit
dazu der klimachef der umweltstiftung
wwf michael schäfer ein gemeinsamer co2
mindestpreis für den stromsektor hat
nicht nur das potenzial die europäische
energiewende voranzutreiben sondern
würde deutschland ermöglichen sein 2020
ziel zu erfüllen andere länder sind da
schon deutlich weiter in frankreich gibt
es seit 2014 einen jährlichen anstieg
der co2 steuer für emissionen
umweltschützer sind der meinung dass der
staat hier frühzeitig den
wirtschaftlichen rahmen setzen muss
damit unternehmen nicht so lange auf
veraltete technologien setzen wird es
deutschland doch noch schaffen
das ist nämlich möglich wie eine studie
des fraunhofer instituts belegt hier im
video berichten wir über diese studie
einfach draufklicken und darunter kommt
jetzt zu unserem whatsapp newsletter nur
da bekommt er täglich vorab den link zum
video und zur begrüßung ein kleines
geschenk einfach draufklicken und
ansonsten abonnieren nicht vergessen bis
dann bleibt dran und die glocke